les épisodes retours sont des épisodes
spéciaux réservés aux membres de ma page
patronne sur ma page patronne vous
trouverez plus d'une centaine de
publications inédites les capsules
concept les 17 minutes les cours en
visio sans parler de mes articles et des
apéro philo
rejoignez-moi sur patriotes pour y
accéder le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour le
nouvel épisode retour qui va être
consacré à mon dernier épisode sur le
portrait du roi arthur dans kaamelott
alors c'est le troisième portrait philo
que je publie sur ma chaîne le premier
était consacré à végétal le deuxième à
rocky balboa et donc vous l'aurez
compris je pense les portraits philo que
je réalise porte sur des figures de la
culture populaire qui ont soit bénigne
et mon enfance ou soit accompagné une
partie de ma vie sachant que je ne suis
pas un grand amateur de séries mais
camelot fait partie des séries que j'ai
suivie et que j'ai visionné plusieurs
fois et je me souviens qu'à l'époque où
j'ai regardé cette série je mettais déjà
fait toutes les réflexions que j'ai
développé dans cet épisode notamment sur
la question de l'absurde et sur le
rapport qu arthur à à la vie est
également sur la signification
métaphysique du graal puisque le graal
c'est un objet dont la signification est
assez impénétrables un objet qui fait se
confronter des interprétations
philosophique ésotérique alchimique et
bien entendu l'interprétation que je
fais du graal dans mon épisode sur le
roi arthur n'a pas la prétention de
dévoiler une vérité ni d'être la seule
interprétation possible bien entendu
mais il se trouve que c'est pendant
l'écriture de cet épisode que m'est
venue cette idée que le graal pourrait
symboliser la conscience de la valeur de
la vie puisque le graal recueille le
sang du christ autrement dit le sang des
innocents le sens d'une victime et que
donc que peut représenter le sang du
christ sinon le crime commis par les
êtres humains d'avoir tué un innocent
et tu es à l'innocence c'est je pense la
meilleure parabole pour illustrer ce
qu'est la valeur de la vie c'est-à-dire
l'injustice fondamentale la justice dont
nous sommes coupables mais au-delà de
cette question du graal et de la
question de l'absurde je trouvais qu'il
y avait beaucoup de choses à dire
philosophiquement parlant sur le
personnage du roi arthur et notamment
son rapport à la justice et ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup plu
lorsque j'ai travaillé sur l'épisode le
fait de rattacher le roi arthur à saint
thomas d'aquin c'est-à-dire un
philosophes et théologiens chrétiens
alors même que le personnage d'arthur et
dénués de la moindre fois religieuse et
d'ailleurs si on sait lire entre les
lignes on s'aperçoit qu'il y a beaucoup
de points communs entre le roi arthur et
alexandre astier lui-même et alexandre
acier s'est déjà prononcée plusieurs
fois publiquement sur la religion en
disant bien que selon lui la religion
est quelque chose qui doit être dépassé
ce qui sous-entend que selon lui la
croyance en dieu relève purement de
l'irrationalité et c'est un peu cet état
d'esprit qu'on retrouve chez le roi
arthur c'est à dire ne croire quand des
choses qui ont un sens logique ne croire
quand des choses issues de l'observation
ou de la pensée rationnelle donc on a
affaire à un roi arthur totalement dénué
de transcendance totalement dénué de
religiosité et pourtant dans son
comportement on trouve un attachement au
sacré un attachement à la justice un
attachement aux sacrifices pour les
causes nobles et ça j'ai trouvé que
c'était intéressant de le mettre en
parallèle avec un penseur chrétien c'est
à dire avec quelqu'un qui ne partage pas
du tout les options religieuses du roi
arthur ou plutôt les noms options
religieuses du roi arthur mais qui le
rejoint dans ses conclusions
et je pense que ça c'est un bon levier
de réflexion sur les origines de la
moralité à savoir qu'on peut être
quelqu'un de morale tout en étant
totalement dénué de foi religieuse on
peut être quelqu'un de très moral sans
croire en dieu et ça ça fait évidemment
référence à une phrase de dostoïevski
qui dit si dieu n'existe pas alors tout
est permis autrement dit il ne peut pas
exister de morale à thé est bien le roi
arthur est la preuve qu'il peut exister
une morale athée mais que cette morale
est forcément source de tensions et de
conflits intérieurs et ce conflit
intérieur j'ai vraiment voulu le
souligner dans mon épisode le fait car
tu reçois tiraillé le fait qu'il soit
déchiré entre deux aspirations
contradictoires une aspiration purement
matérialiste matérialiste au sens
philosophique du terme c'est à dire que
rien d'autre n'existe que la matière est
en même temps une aspiration spirituelle
puisqu'il y a derrière la morale
arthurienne derrière cet honneur
derrière ce sens des valeurs et de la
justice quelque chose qui est témoin
d'un attachement au sacré donc la
question ne peut jamais se résumer de
manière aussi simple que croyant ou
athée
matérialiste où spiritualiste on voit
bien que c'est loin d'être aussi simple
et que le personnage du roi arthur est à
l'image de cette complexité
ce qui m'amène à un nouveau point à
savoir que dans cet épisode j'ai décidé
de mettre de côté la dimension
humoristique de la série la plupart des
fans de kaamelott même la plupart des
gens qui ont entendu parler de camelot
savent que c'est une série humoristique
mais en réalité lorsqu'on regarde
l'intégralité des saisons de la série et
a fortiori lorsqu'on écoute alexandre
astier en parler on s'aperçoit que
l'humour est en réalité un vernis mais
que le coeur de la serre et que le noyau
dur de la série ce n'est pas de faire
rire le coeur de la série c'est de
raconter une histoire de faire vivre
cette histoire est donc de faire naître
les émotions suscitées par cette
histoire et si les deux premières
saisons étaient essentiellement
humoristique bien en réalité ses deux
premières saisons 11 tout servi de
tremplin pour les suivantes c'est à dire
qu'elles ont surtout servi à poser les
éléments de l'intrigué et que des
qu'alexandre astier a eu les mains
libres qu'il a pu modifier son format
qu'il a pu insuffler une nouvelle
orientation à la série eh bien il a pris
le parti de raconter une histoire
dramatique une histoire dramatique voire
une histoire tragique et je pense
peut-être même inconsciemment une
histoire philosophique l'épopée
philosophique du roi arthur
confronté à l'absurdité de l'existence
confronté à une transcendance qui nie
tout temps la subissons et pour être
honnête je ne sais absolument pas si
alexandre astier a introduit tous ces
éléments philosophique volontairement
même si je sais que lorsqu'on parle
d'art et de réalisations artistiques les
catégories de volontaires et d'un
volontaires n'ont plus vraiment de sens
mais je serais quand même curieux de
savoir ce qu'il en pense parce qu'à mon
avis on ne crée pas une oeuvre de cet
acabit philosophique sans au moins se
poser la question la question du sens de
l'histoire qu'on cherche à raconter la
question du message de l'oeuvre en tout
cas la question de l'intention à
l'origine de l'oeuvre
toujours est-il qu'il s'agissait là de
mon troisième portrait philo et que j'ai
déjà ma petite idée sur le personnage
auquel je consacrerai le quatrième
portrait philo mais ça je vous en
parlerai au moment venu
voilà c'est la fin de cet épisode retour
consacrer à mon dernier épisode sur le
roi arthur dans kaamelott je vous
remercie pour votre attention et je vous
dis à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures philosophique
[Musique]